I visit he writes I visited the Creation
Museum purely out of a sense of
mystified curiosity the recorded
narration in their planetarium claimed
that contemporary astrophysics predicted
that certain stars were older than the
known age of the universe and cited this
problem as evidence against science and
for young Earth Creationism I think this
was a real Astrophysical problem for a
while but has since been outmoded by
better models of stars
I was hoping Neil might tell me a little
bit more about the problem and it's
solution which problem the problem that
the Creation Museum exists at all I
think the problem should increase which
lovely it's like a Creation Museum I
think what it is is it's pointing to
some outdated model of understanding
sighs okay so let's unpack whole event
yeah so for actually have nothing
specifically against a Creation Museum
it sure is keep it out of the science
classroom right right we live in a free
country people could taste say whatever
you want about whatever just like the
Batman Museum is not accurate that's
what it means today's bun 3 all right
just don't confuse it with actual
science the so back when was it in the
90s there were measurements of this
before Hubble
settled all these questions the Hubble
telescope that is the we had
measurements of the oldest stars and
they were coming in you know 18 billion
years old and measurements of the age of
the universe that was coming in about 15
billion years old so that was it was an
unsolved problem in astrophysics sounds
like non-existence when you hated that
you can't be older than your mother
oh come on this if you write a
terrestrial version of that each of
those are there was data obtained by
completely independent separate methods
right so I was quite happy that they
were in the same ballpark right 15
billion 18 billion yes a few billion
here are there cosmically speaking that
difference is small it's not one that's
a thousand times older than the other
yes then somebody is not getting doing
something right all right so a few
billion years on 15 billion years was it
was something it was a problem to be
solved but it made much sexier headlines
to talk about than what any been so
scientists relate this all seems pretty
reasonable with more accuracy yeah yeah
that's how we were dealing with it it
wasn't oh my gosh how did you know cuz
what they weren't considering what we
called error bars error bars are you
make a measurement and what is the
uncertainty of that number
there's certainly in the 15 billion year
age of the of the universe was plus or
minus 2 billion years you see these
Everywhere's now these uncertainty
numbers in in election polls
yeah so they became familiar to people
what is the Florida ripple understand
then it's like maybe it's 13 billion
maybe it's 7 maybe a 17 and now you have
the 18 billion year old star yeah that
could be you know that was 18 plus or
minus 2 so the overlap in that it's fine
so the Creation Museum uses science from
the 90s to prove the science is wrong
well write to this wall wrong and the
fact is in NH been a young the universe
as what is put forth by creation folk
that is a universe that's not 6,000
years no more than 10,000 it's a look in
the thousands yeah yeah not billions
okay so these are these are apples and
oranges going on here so by the way it's
possible to have an error bar an
uncertainty range that is completely out
of whack that would mean there's a
systematic error right in your data okay
looks the way that they thought they
created what faster tachyons are know
yeah that was that yeah that was a
thought they'd found particles in the
planet than the Switzerland yeah
traveling faster than white and I there
was a blunder or they were actually
traveling faster than I and we've never
ever seen or measured anything travel
faster sunlight which made was probably
a blunder right it turned out it was a
blunder just a complete blunder and that
that happens so so back then it was a
fascinating story so right now the
universe is is about 14 billion years
the ages of stars all match up we have
better measurements of what goes on
inside of stars that all got resolved
Hubble helped out mightily right so that
that's all that was going on there so
now everything makes perfect sense all
right